a couple easter eggs that just
references that just come to mind uh
when he catches the punch from robbie
that's when he catches the punch from
daniel when he's trained making him
punch his knuckles johnny says you
couldn't leave well not or he still
can't leave well enough alone or
whatever he said that's again call back
to the first film uh we get top gun in
there that movie came out in 1986 amir
the karate kid part 2 came out we also
see peter cetera glory of love that is
the main theme song from karate kid part
two and then obviously we saw bloodsport
in there now and that is no reference to
cricket but we did see johnny looking
that up on his computer when he got the
uh computer for the first time and he
was talking to pawn shop he's like
what's wi-fi what's internet and all
that stuff so he did look up blood
sports so i thought that was pretty cool
and uh yeah
dude
that was delightful
clearly did your research
clearly watch this episode already yeah
what's going on there reject pay
attention because andrew's got a shirt
oh andrew andrew with the shirt thanks
man i had to strike first to get this
shirt and i hope you showed no mercy
yeah and got arrested at the mall we do
not train to be merciful mercy is for
the weak man sees you it's his enemy
andrew's got a sickness guys go rick i
episode four of season four if you guys
can strike that like button that would
be amazeballs if you could subscribe and
click that notification bell that would
be even cooler hey follow us on patreon
become a superject today by checking out
all the content we got to offer over
there full-length watch-alongs for copri
tire available elsa prepper thanks boys
for helping us edit down these
highlights especially tough working with
this guy over here
you got one more one more quote one more
quote
i'm good
all right how about this one party time
world friends
all right there you go
[Music]
district required us to remove anything
that could potentially be used as a
weapon in the event of another
karate incident
what about knowledge knowledge could be
a weapon
okay so this way is the cafeteria
oh my god he's got the merch oh
nice kenny costume andrew logos boy you
got strawberry on your snake shirt
so you've just been letting me walk
around like this at first i thought it
was part of the evil looking design but
then i realized you're just a slob
striker kenny no mercy she's a junior
she's a total chill what's that j-i-l-f
junior i'd like to whoa
do you think you can wear shirt like
that around here
it's from my dojo
maybe they started a kindergarten class
or a nursery
now miyagi does are bullies don't be
teenagers guys
that's not the same asian guy caddy
don't be racist
oh my god word of advice kid get out of
kobrakai while you still can because
they're about to go down and it's not
gonna be pretty
miyagido style hey
hey
hey
hey
hey
he's so jealous
hey
hey
whoa
dude take a tooth out with that
all right remember the best ways to get
a point
hang in there dimitri
literally
very nice
sorry
nice kick
remember with that foot through the
target let all your aggression disappear
[Music]
no no no no very good suck it up tighten
that cord
[Laughter]
oh hungry
i'll make your favorite spicy man with
cider steak fries
oh i'm actually going with mr larusso
ooh
oh okay no problem
sensei
you ready when you are oh no you thought
it was pretty cool
you got some free tickets to the driving
tonight i think they're going old school
with this something called bloodsport
1988 newt arnold as you know our enemies
are working together
they are combining their styles to beat
us however that doesn't mean that we
can't double down
class
meet sensei terry silva oh boy
welcome back terry look at that dude but
if you dig in
and follow our lead
we're gonna take you to the next level
he sounded like his older self maybe
you're just tired
i swear this has never ever happened
strike soft you know working at the
hospital
i do have access to certain
medications
what i don't need pills
i'm 100
all man i'm just sad about miguel this
can't get larusso and miguel out of my
head
did you know larusso showed miguel top
gun
i love that movie
cruz is the worst in that here you got
the real deal iceman best of the best
one
can't call yourself a maverick
i didn't even earn a spot at miramar
i was wingman killed too not cool
i want johnny to have his own review
channel
i feel guilty sneaking around
it's not good to carry secrets like this
they weigh you down yeah andrew jeez man
you can tell him johnny
when you're ready
but i know it'll make you feel better
how can you sleep all that sun coming no
clothes are blind
you start it up start it up
oh
success
you got to get to a party and meet
amanda and sam i'm running late let's go
what
i don't know how to drive a car
oh well then i suggest you back us out
nice and slow
okay you're gonna start with back it up
is this like i don't know how to start
drive a car like and he didn't have a
license and he had to drive miyagi
around i don't think it's anything like
that i'm talking about it
i'm done you're doing great
don't break
okay
like i'd tell you the insulin went too
annoyed
this is just about the last place i'd
like to be spending my saturday a lot of
people have it worse
no
oh
i love this show i love this show so
much
[Music]
is that the ace ventura's jacket tammy
come on more red
it's tori or whatever just hurry up
let's go ladies it's show time
tori i'm so proud of you you went up a
lot in my book
a character arc for greg right now
[Applause]
did i say the last place i want to spend
saturday
she really is spoiled dude focus on your
combos really use that speed let's go
come on i've got all the moves down
oh really kick his ass robbie
always going for the sweep the leg hey
worked in mortal kombat man
[Laughter]
all right miyagido i was taught you can
learn all the moves but none of that
matters unless you have balance balance
is crucial
a man can't stand
mm-hmm
he can't fight
oh he snapped trained in miyagido now
cobra kai
you'll have enough skills to kick all
our asses
i kick mine right now
show me
what's the matter you're afraid to hit
an old man come on
show me it's funny how he just seems
like
it's weird
slid right back into it
damn
you need to dig out that fear and face
it whatever it is
because if you don't
it's gonna hold you back forever
that's a good lesson
why do you stop watching
even johnny's porn ads are from the 90s
you'll never get past me
yes i will i'm american hero
oh do you remember that man said that we
went out to dinner with the fat ball guy
don't say that
he proposed isn't it beautiful
this means you're gonna have a new daddy
i don't want a new daddy he's afraid
miguel's gonna react like that what do
you have there
oh he drinks the same beer as daddy
drink he left us you have a new daddy
now now go to bed
don't be like your dad yeah well not
everything from the 80s was hard rock
it was some soft rock songs that were
just
perfect that's a reference to the rock
in his backyard
good one the sad part is i have a dad
you ever see him
i don't know much about him
it is hiba who predicted that here were
you
my mom was pregnant and tried to get him
to stop and
he wouldn't toxic waste
oh no
i looked him up
it says he lives in mexico now maybe not
that's not terrible
it's el chapo
it may not seem brave but sometimes
avoiding conflict is one of the most
heroic things a person can do shut up
john
maybe i'm just saying prince did
everything he could to climb the
mountain the dragon carried me there so
he could eat me alive but then the
valiant prince came to my rescue oh is
that the prince that you stole from
another princess
now i had to save the prince using what
a weapon like
i don't know a spiked bracelet or
nunchucks by
singing a magic song oh and how did the
song go yeah sing us the song oh oh
golly when you hear the sound of thunder
beautiful dragon
please go to sleep
sunset is falling now time to count
wow and i thought you were bad at
fighting
oh oh come on she's trying sam why are
these kids at a burlesque club i know
why is the dressing room literally a
strip club dressing room didn't put the
dragon to sleep instead it turned it
into an evil witch and that witch has
been spotted at kids parties all over
the valley oh no the way she can be
destroyed is with a glitter ball
uh uh what are you doing
getting about to get fired from another
job there she is now trying to blend in
with the crowd
[Music]
damn tory she was smart though she got
the kids to do it i don't know who to be
angry at
it's good drama you put all your trust
in greece
i don't trust anyone anymore you don't
know the whole story i know enough and i
know it's been holding me back because
for as long as i can remember i've been
afraid
afraid that i would end up like you ouch
that fear again
because i'm better than you
hey honey okay uh sorry i'm late
uh choice you're going for the uh disco
ball look uh
hmm
no do it yeah
i'm sorry about sam but tell that to her
just know that the world isn't out to
get you
no one can help you if you don't let
them
if you ask
you might be surprised just kind of work
at larusso otto it's a good lesson john
for you uh you know i will uh
john's definitely the tourney of the
trio here
let me be back on my mermaid songs
coca-cola throws out a lot of money for
this show man
get that product is like put it right in
front of the camera
there's another coors there i want a
coke
[Laughter]
hey miguel
come over for a bite
something i've been wanting to talk to
you about
oh yeah sure i i mean i just had an
early dinner with the larusso's though
you know it seems you've been spending a
lot of time with larusso lately
yeah i guess i mean
paid for my mom's car showed me how to
fix an engine and today you taught me
how to drive you did what uh-oh
how come you haven't told me about
chicago what happened in chicago no
the band you know uh you're the
inspiration gloria love ooh that's
correct part two what happened to
scorpions slaughter is out the window no
they're cool too it's just different as
well yeah very different
okay look what did you want to talk
about
nothing
do your thing
oh poor jotty
let's do dinner tomorrow you can make
those man wishes
oh yeah sure
okay
but it just made some manly ads a dip
and he put beef jerky in oh bloodsport
man i'm killing this movie man this is
john claude
oh
that move is coming back
let's come back in the finale
here's your stuff hey yo [ __ ] boy
[ __ ] boy ah
so give me two buckets of popcorn with
butter four large cokes two hot dogs
with mustard no ketchup and a pretzel
you'll be way too fat for this karate
turn right now
and your chunks all over everybody
signature move just keep your head up
you'll earn respect
got it
and um
give me a butterfinger
oh man robbie you might be the greatest
manipulator
without realizing it that's a risk i'm
willing to take
these guys again no no
no
what the [ __ ] hock look who it is
you betrayed me agito
traitor oh there's a traitor here for
sure
he's gonna get what he deserves
i don't think so
not if i have anything to say about it
what the [ __ ]
we beat him on the map oh really you do
remember what happened the last time we
fought right
okay oh
we just hit the baseball diamond in 30
minutes
and no weapons oh you won't meet them
they're going to play a game of baseball
[Laughter]
just like twilight
[Laughter]
or maybe they don't show up that's the
prank they turn them sprinklers get the
happy gilmore moment
yeah yeah the happy gilmore moment way
to go
you can't let them get away with it
going to turn on the sprinklers on all
their houses what the city
cobra kai it was never about revenge
it was about building strength by taking
your fears and turning them into a
weapon
that's what we should be focused on
that's gonna say let's get mike barnes i
know the show's good at avoiding stand
down and do
nothing
i didn't say we'd do nothing
put snakes in their car dealership i
found a way to get out of a bad
situation without anyone getting hurt
what'd you want him to do get in a
drive-in switchblade fight i'm proud of
you
you've taken miyagido teachings to heart
i'm your new dad oh boy
what
oh terry and daniel i love this oh
[ __ ]
oh
[ __ ]
danny boy
i did not see this coming gentlemen
[Music]
it seems we have a few things to discuss
[Music]
oh man that was awesome love it god love
it all had a great bit i didn't record
any of it oh no oh damn it sorry don't
i'll repeat it in the next video yeah do
it no one will even know i don't even
know unless they stuck around for this
review guys
damn what a good episode it's kind of
rain it's ramping up man
i have a feeling i'm going to end up
really liking tori a lot
and understanding her as a human
being i already get it i get it she has
to be the mother of the household in a
time where her family is low income
and sucks man she's got the short of the
stick all the time
seems like she's dealt with a lot of
abuse as well it's gotta be a tough one
i get it she's just always angry and
it's kind of off putting out to you know
what i mean
i'm just so small once in a while
despite all those life circumstances i
pretty much met
so much great things happening here uh
andrew what'd you think of the episode i
thought it was interesting how we saw a
lot of the miyagi waiting for me to say
you know
let's just get into it i'll do your
easter eggs in a sec but i thought it
was interesting that the miyagi doe
students became the aggressors in the
boy you can see that johnny's teachings
are really having an influence on ones
who you would never associate with being
aggressive and striking first whereas
the eagle fang students aka miguel is
more of like the restrainer and the
de-escalator he's learning from daniel
so it's interesting to see that uh you
know the compact between the two and how
different they can be after one
influences one side and one influences
the other so i i almost didn't recognize
any of the
miyagido students after uh you know they
were the ones being the aggressors and
the bullies it was interesting towards
kenny yeah yeah i didn't recognize them
at first either yeah definitely i'm
talking about the way they they were
acting man geez but uh in regards i
meant really i was like wait a minute
it's too rare
yeah
but in regards to uh and obviously that
moment at the end we're seeing just
terry and daniel in the same frame again
was freaking awesome i can't wait to see
that scene in the next episode a couple
easter eggs that just references that
just come to mind uh when he catches the
punch from robbie that's when he catches
the punch from daniel when he's trained
making him punch his knuckles uh we're
not gonna roll that footage just use
your memory yeah we hear him say uh
johnny says you couldn't leave well not
or he still can't leave well enough
alone or whatever he said that's again
call back to the first film uh we get
top gun in there that movie came out in
1986 samir the karate kid part 2 came
out we also see peter satera glory of
love that is the main theme song from
karate kid part two
uh
yeah and then obviously we saw
bloodsport in there now and that is no
reference to cricket but we did see
johnny looking that up on his computer
when he got the computer for the first
time and he was talking to pawn shop
he's like what's wi-fi what's internet
and all that stuff so he did look up
blood sports so i thought that was
pretty cool and uh yeah
dude
it was delightful
[Laughter]
and obviously to the happy gilmore thing
uh with uh getting the shooter mcgavin
tricking happy to getting the uh is it a
happy gilmore reference or just a thing
that they sometimes do in movies and
shows no it's a happy gilmore reference
yeah because i said so especially and
you you were wanting one last last one
uh when they were at what balboa park
right yeah yeah yeah yeah
i called that what year did rocky 4 come
out rocky 4 1985 1985 which is one year
before karate kid 2 that's correct which
has apollo creed which has carl weathers
in happy killing
boom easter eggs
happy girls degrees of easter eggs yeah
amazing oh boy
the things you missed come to this video
let's put the thumbnail with arrows and
and yeah somebody in a certain way yeah
yeah we got this man
it was all in the hips
but no i agree with exactly what you
what you said there you know seeing uh i
mean like that's perhaps the most
apparent thread of the episode but yeah
watching as the miyagi doe eagle fang
kids devolve into the very people they
were up against before which which is an
interesting bit to me because a little
bit i'm like guys don't forget where you
came from but also you know they're
they're teenagers and whatnot and i
liked
the sort of way this episode embodies
the actual dynamic that johnny and danny
have when imparting knowledge to their
students it's like you can see them
learning these different schools of
thought from each of them but the
conflict brewing between danny and
johnny equals the conflict in how the
kids express what they're actually being
taught and the ways in which they've
taken a lot of that stuff to heart in
kind of the wrong way or not quite the
right way yeah so as to cast at least
our sort of protagonist kids in more of
the villainous light now or the
antagonistic light now uh whereas you
know cobra cry for as crazy as crease is
you know cobra kai seems to be coming
out a little more level head at least
robbie's a little more level-headed at
this point yeah i think what they do
really good is that they they let the
philosophies of each school
affect the character development of
whoever is really being focused on being
taught as a student
there that's the one sentence way you
could have said all that wow you see
that oh man brevity is the soul of
compacting your sentence
into a witty way of making it all happen
i also thought this episode did a really
good job just balancing out the drama i
mean from when it comes to miguel and
johnny with daniel and then with torrey
seeing sam and miguel like there was a
good balance there that i and obviously
too with robbie not liking the way uh
they were bullying uh with kenny so i
thought this episode was really balanced
as miyagi always says and uh yeah that
was really it was really interesting
well i think robbie
hold on andrew
just hold it i just remembered another
reference hold it hold it for oh yeah i
don't anticipate they're not going to
listen to anything i'm about to say next
we're just just waiting for reference
to see that reference
i really i really love how they've been
developing robbie a lot in particular
the two standout characters to me in
this episode were robbie and terry
silver because robbie
when he has that speech with johnny
about you know like there's a different
i
i don't know what to really believe
because it was robbie's ultimate choice
to go back there was he encouraged by
kris absolutely has this show really
demonstrated that crease can be this
great snake of a manipulator to the
point where even as an audience member i
sometimes question the integrity of some
of these people like i'm kind of sitting
here going
we don't really see crease manipulating
robbie too much you mean terry
crease manipulating robbie
oh yeah okay sorry robbie's a character
who's no because
because terry and robbie had that whole
thing but then robbie had it like what
are you afraid of and all that you know
when johnny that we just watched the
hold that reference when johnny
said
that you know he's creates manipulating
you and robbie's like he's not it's
different to me and you i'm just using
as a means to get what i want part of me
is wondering how where is robbie of this
and is this just his own choice and i
think he does a great job like the
relationship that he builds with kenny
as well i like he really does seem like
the sweetheart at cobra county like the
one who's actually a little bit nicer
more understanding more endearing
towards others and then when he embodies
the part of i am the enemy to miyagi doe
or eagle fang you see that perspective
as well it's really good at shifting the
perspectives that's what i think this
show has me as a good job of making me
go it was all it was all in the scene at
the uh kids party um with all the
strippers you know
that was that was
made up
what dimension is this kid's
establishment from well no it's one of
those like disney princess parties right
yeah yeah yeah yeah just they framed it
in a way like they were in the behind
the scenes
about to become show girl okay
they did freight because it's like i
know a lot of people have done those
jobs yeah and uh it's a good p it's a
good gig and uh i think even simu liu um
asian that's a reference to karate kid
andrew hold that reference yeah
uh
i got another one all right all those
two references so
assuming spider-man and then terry
silver you know the the way they're
flushing him out too i think is great
because
what i found so eerie was when he first
showed up in this in this episode or in
the show
he seemed like a different guy like like
it was a different actor you know like
it's like the same guy
and then now that he's back at teaching
a cobra kind of like oh wow he he does
seem like the guy the same guy from
karate kid three just older
and then yet they have a great moment
where he's talking with crease
about not living in the past or not just
trying to rehash it
that you still see that he hasn't just
like had some switch go off as alone
where he is completely blinded and he's
like right back in the 80s he's not
reverted yet yeah he's not but kind of
he's he's like partially there he's
reverted with some wisdom yeah you know
with the wisdom of now but the attitude
of them yeah yeah so i think uh i think
his pro i think his acting is still so
strong you said he was retired retired
he's retired he comes back and he's i
think he's like he's in such an amazing
job so great he's so good he's so he's
so amazing
and um what's her two references so the
two references i kind of mentioned it
while we were watching it but one of
them was having daniel have uh miguel
drive without a license daniel drove
without license with miyagi too and also
too we got
uh what's his name terry silver duh
brain fire terry silver was uh when he
says a man can't stand he can't fight
said the exact same thing to daniel and
karate kid part three wow
that friggin terry silva yeah man and i
think like he is like i love so as much
as it is like kind of the meme of this
show of like every season we're gonna
bring back somebody like his presence is
so terrific hillary swank next season i
hope so honestly i would love it but uh
like with terry silver like i i guess
that's why i got confused before because
i think through the conversation with
you know crease and all that stuff you
have a great temper to all that with
terry because
you know you know his sociopathic
abilities and me as an audience member i
love this dance of being like i can't
tell if he's saner and more effective
than ever or like way more off the deep
end yeah it's a great nuance i think the
show's doing a really good job just with
this episode alone of establishing the
uh the necessity of terry silver
you know like whereas in karate kid 3 it
felt more like
new villainy
i really enjoyed him but we need a fresh
face for the cobra kai villain let's
make him more extreme and push crease to
the side for most of this and then here
you know when you're hearing about like
i need you back part of me would wonder
why why would you really need him back
and i think this episode alone really
showed a showed us exactly don't worry
andrew i'll let you get that in i see
that hand movement i know what that
means when you're like
i got you andrew yeah you're under the
microscope now andrew yes right i see
everything everything everything is
sorry andrew you bring such a different
dynamic that this is what i do we were
talking about chris and terry silver
needing each other yeah it doesn't
matter anymore it's good it's good stuff
good and me and johnny and miguel that's
hard that is a that is a really well
fleshed out gray area too like it's
conflicting it's [ __ ] awkward to just
be like how do i go about this you know
he's not really like he's like my kid
but he's not my kid he's my kid and then
we're
we're supposed to be having this
trade-off and everything and i'm
learning he has such a hard time
adapting to change and how it's
triggering his own psychological traumas
as a kid as well i think a lot of that
is very human and and the way they
and the way they're just causing a
divide more more this gap between johnny
and
uh daniel
because miguel is like the heart of the
situation yeah it's a miguel shaped void
in their relationship with origin andrew
one last thing i thought it was also
interesting that uh we got to see more
of amanda sympathizing being empathetic
towards tory
my i mean obviously she knows the
situation that she doesn't have a lot of
uh you know food money rather to pay and
she doesn't have her mother to rely on
kind of feeling like maybe amanda went
through the same thing while she was
growing up and that's why she maybe even
empathizes as much as she does so
they're doing a spin-off amanda origins
all right she's just gonna stay awake
amanda but i like i like how that was uh
executed because uh that actress
courtney hey hey i can't remember their
last name but
yeah there was a gazillion unimportant
facts about the karate kid so you think
i'd remember that
i like the way that
i actually like that portion of the
story and how that's being executed and
yeah i mean like you said earlier too
i'm really empathizing and being very
sympathetic towards tory just i mean
yeah there's moments where you like god
i hate her but there's other moments
they're like okay i can understand where
she's coming from and why she's doing
what she's doing so well i think the
back and forth
at this show does such a good job at
making me go oh man i know to root for
yeah was it was really actually
showcasing the scene at the that's what
i was that's why i was trying to talk
about it
like six minutes ago
was the it was the party with the
princesses because
it kept flipping for me it's like oh sam
you're being a [ __ ]
and then i was like
oh i feel so bad for tori and i was like
oh torey you're being a [ __ ]
they both just had me going back and
forth in this one sequence i'm like ah
crap i guess i'm like that's what i
realized it's going because i'm going to
look at tori quite a bit now yeah
look out we'll see oh i hope she does
something so messed up yeah i hope she
like beheads somebody she's going to
work at la russo otto yeah she's going
to be stream
no
no
she could be like a car showcase girl
yeah yeah do you come with the car
oh you
shawn
shopping
yes
yeah in the simpsons episode cobra kai
we're done with this
we're not right
anymore subscribe hit that like button
say hi to your god forbid but not before
we do a page
gene geeter gene jeter jeter all right
gene you have been selected by the great
and wise and almighty
andrew gordon sorry i butchered your
name man my bad i want to thank john for
leaving the screen on ultra bright while
we did this shout out because you will
never have to worry about wrestling
this is the sun speaking to you directly
from
socal gene jeter
we should probably apologize
we agreed that we would shout you out on
a community post
and uh got around to it nauseously late
so obnoxious what was that video john oh
it was a bunch of different people
talking about gene's new book sub to ego
including like double toasted some other
internet personalities and such you know
describing their feelings on the book
and the general vibe there and sub the
egos
nothing is subbing to your own ego like
putting together a compilation of people
talking about your work that's right
watch this guys
watch us do this
but gene you've been part of our patreon
page for far too long it's time for you
to move on
it's time for you to start your own
patreon starter you've now
understood what a patreon is after all
this time create your own or pledge to
someone else have you considered blind
weights oh yeah they're great they're
really low on pledges
they need help and they could use some
more patrons join the blind they are
failing terribly
but if you choose to stay here we
appreciate it
oh yeah happy new year
[Music]